debido en hampton pasó tres años en
prisión tras ser liberado pensó que
había cumplido su condena
fui condenado por tráfico de cocaína
pase de 36 meses detenido aquí en
florida y cuando salí supe que no tenía
derecho al voto
sin embargo de avión ha sido privado de
su derecho parcialmente para poder ir a
las urnas debe pagar todas sus deudas
con la justicia esto tras la aprobación
de una nueva ley que fue firmada en 2019
por el gobernador republicano de florida
ron de santis cercano al presidente de
donald trump
pero estas altas tarifas son a menudo
imposibles de pagar para los ex
convictos que son en su mayoría de
origen humilde librada en 2007 después
de dos años de prisión por fraude maría
estévez le debe al estado 500.000
dólares
15 años pagando y 15 años que me están
quitando dinero de mi retiro de algo que
yo trabajé yo creo que eso es suficiente
cada mes el gobierno le descuenta el 15
por ciento de los 800 dólares que
devenga para los demócratas esto es
interpretado como un intento por
restringir el derecho a votar a las
minorías que con frecuencia eligen a
candidatos de su partido
la solución organizar colectas el
multimillonario michael bloomberg ha
ayudado a recaudar más de 20 millones de
dólares y ha sido apoyado por
celebridades como el cantante john
legend o la estrella del baloncesto
michael jordan furiosos los republicanos
denuncian una compra de votos con 29
sufragios en el colegio electoral
florida es tradicionalmente un estado
clave para las presidenciales pero esta
nueva ley podría tener un impacto real
en las elecciones del 3 de noviembre